welcome back time for sport night
history sahel thank you very much well
we start with some breaking news out of
japan
where organizers of the tokyo olympics
have just confirmed that overseas fans
will not be allowed to attend it doesn't
come as a surprise as several reports in
recent weeks suggested the japanese
government
had already made up its mind the main
reason for blocking foreign supporters
is to reduce the risk of spreading
coronavirus
the games have already been delayed by
one year because
of the pandemic well let's bring in
british olympian le taylor mohammed
in manchester who will be competing in
taekwondo at the tokyo games
lotelo overseas fans won't be able to
come and watch you compete
how does that make you feel well
i think it was probably to be expected
we've had such
an unusual year um with you know the
kobe
pandemic that i guess it kind of makes
sense
but it definitely will be different for
me one of the biggest things about the
olympics is having that
uh support uh you know flying from home
obviously family and friends
so an olympics without that is going to
be weird but let's face it it's been a
very weird year
it really has and what about the
japanese fans i know that
uh you you were telling me earlier that
you're expecting a specific atmosphere
when you get there from them
yes i mean the japanese fans are
notorious for being
very quiet and very polite it's um
like small influxes of excitement then
it goes very quiet again
so i'm very fortunate to have competed
in japan before
so i'll be used to it but i think it's
going to be
a bit of a a culture shock for
many olympians who have been at previous
sports events
um it's going to be a bit different
however
um it is what it is i'm just very happy
and grateful that the olympics is
happening
and uh why not why not uh
different doesn't always mean bad it
certainly doesn't well there's been a
lot of talk about the athletes
being vaccinated before they get to
tokyo what's your own situation will you
be vaccinated and has
team gb said anything to you about
vaccinating
the team i would not be getting
vaccinated the
message i have received from team gb is
that there will be no mandatory vaccine
um i'm of the mindset that is not
necessary
i have full confidence in the japanese
organizing committee
the ioc and team gb to uh
make this the safest cleanest
um environment that has ever been for an
olympics
in history with the global pandemic
situation
i think we can all expect that so i
don't think
uh the vaccine uh will be made mandatory
for the athletes because i think
the japanese organizing committee is
gonna do everything they can
we've just seen what uh what they're
doing with the foreign fans not being
allowed to
uh come in they're gonna do everything
they can to make sure it's safe
for all the athletes we spoke to you at
the end of last year about
training in this pandemic you've been
quite lucky you've been able to train
but some athletes haven't been able to
train they haven't had the access to
facilities so
are you concerned about the tokyo
olympics being a level playing field
i think it's going to be a real concern
we are right now
currently seeing a third wave going
across europe
i believe paris and some areas of france
are going to be shut down for
one month um i know italy is
uh now going back into a lockdown or
maybe in a lockdown already
so that's gonna affect many athletes
across the globe not just in europe i
know um
toronto and uh some parts of canada um
so these are big nations who we normally
expect to win
big medals at the olympics my heart goes
out
to those athletes who uh their training
schedule
which has already been massively
affected
um is going to be uh
even more affected um we are very
fortunate at gb
taekwondo where we've been allowed to
train due to our elite athlete exemption
uh it's been very organized and very
grateful for that but across the world
i know that is not the case for
everybody plenty of quarantine
and uh lack of access to facilities
another thing that nobody is really
mentioning is the qualification
situation
half of the athletes have still not been
able to qualify
due to the cobit pandemic so that's
massive in itself i believe the boxing
qualification um the tournament got
halfway through
half the athletes qualified then they
had to cancel the tournament last year
so
there's half of the boxes still waiting
to know
what's going on and that's not just
boxing that's across all the sports so
there's a lot of uh things that clear up
in this four months before
we get to tokyo and just very briefly
you've got four months now to prepare
how are you feeling are you feeling
gold medal fit i'm feeling
very very fit um yes uh bronze in
london uh silva in rio and i'll let you
finish
or the only medal i'm chasing in tokyo
is that gold medal
um it's been difficult uh it's been hard
to focus
uh to maintain focus but thankfully i've
got a wonderful team around me
gary hall's a tremendous leader great
coaches great athletes
and we've all helped each other to get
to this point so i'm feeling
gold medal fits and i can't wait for the
opportunity to get back
on that podium and on top this time
because i want to be number one
well you sound so positive and we wish
you all the best in tokyo
la taylor mohammed thank you very much
for speaking to us
thank you very much for having me and
i'm always positive